Believe It or Not uh I use my schedule I
mean I'm a slave to my schedule like so
many other people and I open my schedule
and I go okay that's my
week yeah um and so I literally build
the balance in um um I will block off an
entire Friday for example and though I
will work on Fridays no one is allowed
to schedule anything on Friday so I I've
no prescheduled anything on a Friday um
and that allows me to have creative time
but it allows me to build in that
balance and um um I've been doing that
for years and it wasn't necessarily a
whole Friday some it was a few hours so
between these hours and these hours you
know this hour and this hour I wouldn't
schedule anything and I was protective
of it um so for example and and like we
think of things like working out you
know we we we think of these things as
flexible or we put in Creative time we
think of it as flexible and somebody
says oh can I see you at 3:00 and you
look in your calendar and you know three
o'clock was your workout or three
o'clock was your your creative time and
you go yeah I can do three and I say oh
sorry I have something else at three
what you know do you have any other
options yeah I I'm very protective now
it's not ideal sometimes if it's very
important of course I I can make the
shift um but I'm I'm really protective
of those of those blocks that I block
out for working out or for for Creative
time they're just they're not available
they don't have to know why I can't see
them sure you know I don't think anybody
wants to know I can't meet with you
because I'm working out but sometimes
that's what it is um I'm just really
protective of those
times